[Music]
milk
it's the elixir all mammals feed to
their young deep inside the National Zoo
in Washington DC a team of scientists
are devoted to unlocking the wonders of
the white gold to help animals like baby
fiona but more on that later welcome to
the world's largest collection of exotic
animal milk okay let's get to it
meet dr. Michael power can I call you
Mike sure okay Mike what do you do here
I'm the curator of the exotic animal
milk repository at the Smithsonian's
National Zoo
it's the largest by a species count a
number of samples of milk in the entire
world we have samples that have been
collected from all over the world that
we keep in frozen storage animals like
armadillos bats giraffe giant anteater
Asian elephant African lion
cheetahs tigers sea lions and zebra I
hate to ask but how do you get the milk
well I'll let the Tang show you the Tang
is a critically endangered Bornean
orangutan so this is the classic
collaboration between a scientist and
the animal care staff their incredible
work and effort it be able to training
the animals to be able to accept this
procedure to where they voluntarily
donate samples so now that we know the
how we have to ask why the exotic mammal
milk repository serves two critical
purposes one is basic science that's
simply trying to understand in a sense
the origin of milk and the other is a
very practical pragmatic purpose in the
fact that we have to occasionally
handler animals and therefore we have to
come up with a milk replacer formula
okay so when a baby can't be fed by
their mother you guys help come up with
a formula that's as close to the
mother's milk as possible have you heard
about baby Fiona the cents an
zoo is the baby hippo who's stolen the
hearts of people all over the country
baby fiona was born six weeks premature
she's a now hippo and no other baby
hippo had been hand raised in North
America and so we needed to put together
a milk formula to be able to feed her to
have her grow so we worked together with
the exotic animal milk repository at the
National Zoo to come up with formula to
feed baby whew
so how's Fiona doing now milk is almost
removed from her diet we're very happy
that baby Shona is happy and healthy and
growing very well awesome back to Mike
so what's next the milk repository has
samples from over a hundred and eighty
species of mammals and that sounds
pretty impressive until you realize that
there's anywhere from five to six
thousand species of mammals so we have
only sampled maybe three percent of the
mammals still only a tiny tip of the
iceberg compared to what we could be
learning
[Music]
[Music]
so we have about 500 venomous snakes in
there a serpent I'm not vital any of
this venomous snake could kill you
that's why we're working here we are
collecting Venom's to prevent them my
name is Aaron Gomez I'm the coordinator
of the second time this is a Central
America coral snake you get bit you can
stop breathing and die this is a new
tropical rattlesnake it bites you you
can die after several minutes so it is
estimated that our around 800,000 to 1
million people are getting bitten by
venomous snakes every year we need the
snakes to in order to produce anti-venom
we had known many rocks making that
anti-venom
just like six we estimate to produce
around 100,000 vials per year so we
handle the snake we apply some massage
in them and the muscles of the head and
then we collect the venom in this time
of special flasks then we process the
venom we twist right and then we collect
the venom in powder form and that venom
is going to use to to produce the
anti-venom if you get bit by a viper or
coral snake again in America Central
America the sign the chances are you're
getting anti-venom produced by Institute
are very very high so this is terciopelo
and this one can kill you all right drop
that kill most of the people just
fearlessness let's say there I'm not
afraid but I have respect off his leg
and you never I never made me thank God
[Music]
in my work I really tried to re put you
this smell scenarios for different
purposes
it 3p the neighborhood in the city I've
done curse or smell all over the world
could we on behalf of a small molecule
find out something about history but we
otherwise would know this is sisal
Tallis she has many things an artist a
scientist but more importantly a smell
expert she however prefers another title
I'm call myself a professional
in-betweener which means what exactly
there's a whole world to smell and the
whole word to indicate how to smell so
you cannot just limit yourself to one
discipline right the point is she has
dedicated her life to the sense of smell
what it means but how it can be used to
better understand the world in each
other pretty early in my life I started
asked questions why are we only
understanding the world on behalf of how
the world look like what if we started
using other senses more appropriate for
the same purpose as I went starting to
discover the same world I've been
looking at for several years using the
nose for the purpose so how exactly did
you go about recording and then
reproducing these smells I will walk
around identify smells with my own nose
I have small devices that enable me to
collect the smell molecules emitting
from the source with the result I go to
my lab and then the data I get is then
the starting point of reproduction of
the actual smell I have a lab consisting
of up to 4,000 chemical compounds and
with those ingredients as with those
compounds literally reproduce invisible
reality that surround you full-time all
the time
name a city a neighborhood within a
neighborhood a historical building or
even an era in time and most likely
sizzle has reproduced that smell along
with thousands of other cents here in
her lab with the hopes of using the
findings for a bigger purpose the
purpose can be tolerance education
navigation to memorize the list is
endless is more interesting if you
really start understand the smells and
see how you can use that information for
a purpose beyond the smell itself
[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you the dryads
is taking the thermal energy from the
water unfortunately i instantaneously
get judged on my appearance that is very
frustrating for me so i'm gonna pick up
my hot water when i come over here and
i'm going to throw it right into my
bucket okay it means I have to work
harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it and one my name is
dr. Katie Bergdorf and I am a lecturer
at the University of Texas at Austin I'm
trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is I am not wearing a bow tie
I'm not wearing suspenders I don't have
some frumpy cardigan on I'm just some
regular girl who likes to play with fire
I also really like designer shoes and
that's okay as the alginate hits the
calcium chloride the alginate would
prefer to be with the two plus charge
calcium instead of the one plus charge
sodium and what happens is we form gummy
worms doesn't matter what you look like
any human can be a scientist I
[Music]
definitely try to use energy and
excitement
I do my best to try to reach students
that might be intimidated by science I
use anything that will make the four
hundred and eighty-three students sit up
straight and actually listen to the
words coming out of your mouth as soon
as I've exploded something in their face
I have their attention for just 60
seconds and I can do whatever I can to
shove that knowledge right into their
brains
okay so what we're gonna do today is
doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different hands-on experiments I
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic I'm so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it the fact that I've been able to
master it but then use science to start
the conversation but then physically
stand there and break that image it's
the most rewarding thing I could ever do
ever
[Music]
the Harvard brain Bank is one of the
largest brain banks in the country
at the moment we house approximately
5000 brain specimens my name is Sabina
Bogota
I am the scientific director of the
Harvard brain tissue resource center
which we affectionately call Harvard
brain bank our mission is to collect
brain specimens store them characterize
them and then redistribute them out to
investigators across the world the do
research on the human brain and in
particular on large number of
neurological and psychiatric brain
disorders such as schizophrenia bipolar
disorder Parkinson Huntington and many
others the brain bank never sleeps we
have two sets of people that are gone
called 24/7 we have a very limited time
window from when the person passes away
to the time
and with this all processing so this is
gonna be you first rain late at night
right we have to do it in less than 24
hours our courier will bring it from a
Klein hospital to the brain Bank so just
put it out here so we're gonna take
ourselves it will be a dissection is
ready to dissect the brain
[Music]
that involves so separating the two
hemispheres one of the two hemispheres
is put in a solution that preserves it
the other hemisphere will be dissected
in thick sections and those will be
frozen we are not even close to
understand a lot of what we take for
granted our thoughts were instincts our
feelings our emotions there are a lot of
questions we still don't know and a lot
of our brain functions still will
probably be studied for a long time to
come
a brain donation is in a very concrete
way a gift of knowledge and it cannot be
done without the help of families and
people willing to donate a brain
[Music]